so Ben and I were just walking around  Rite Aid and found freezes crunchy  cookie which I have never seen  apparently they came out like mid May of  this year but it's new to both of us  never seen it before super excited  cookies and Reese's  the best things in the world crunchy  cookie I feel like this is a trick  it's just smells like glory oh the  chocolate came off and I thought the  inside  [Music]  oh my god I love it it's a mad genius  thought of this I'm know if I can go  back to regular racism look at the tiny  chocolate chips  it's everything Reese's wasn't missing  but you never knew you needed do change  you've outdone yourself sir I don't like  when people mess with a good thing like  that was so good I'm really sad that  it's over this is gonna be the new  standard for my Reese's consumption like  I don't think I could go back final doc  you killing the game girl  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]